For the second night running, Grenfell Tower burned.
Pockets of fire remained in difficult-to-reach places.
Fire crews have searched almost all the building.
But the toll of this blaze is still far from
clear.
Residents of the tower block spent the night in makeshift shelters.
The ordeal they have been through is difficult to imagine.
And that ordeal continues -- as they wait
for news of loved ones, friends, neighbours.
So many are missing.
And so many must be feared dead.
Amid the grief and horror,
the question why.
How could this building, renovated only last year, be engulfed so quickly?
How could safety measures apparently fail?
"The fire was quite small to start off with.
There was a gentleman standing in the crowd stating that that
was his flat that was on
fire, and a refrigerator had blown up.
Like I said, very small fire.
And within minutes, from the left and right
and above, it just spread so rapidly."
"It's the cladding, it's the cladding.
I spoke to a resident who had been living
there for 40 years and she said that there
has been fires there but they've always been contained.
This is the first fire that has spread around the building and spread so fast and that cladding
went up less than a year ago."
"But the problem is, there are no fire alarms running, working.
I don't know why."
"I haven't heard no alarm.
I've only heard in my house smoke alarm."
An activist group says it had been predicting
a catastrophe for years.
This is one image from the group's website.
"We repeatedly reported concerns to the tenant management organisation for Kensington and
Chelsea including the fire safety concerns
which were not investigated during the regeneration
works."
The authorities are promising a full investigation.
It's still far too early to really know what
happened.
Amid the trauma -- signs of solidarity.
Food, clothes, toys -- donations have been
pouring in, for those who lost their homes
and everything in them.
"The response is unbelievable, I mean the
church was filled with donations almost by
ten o'clock."
“We love our community, we love our community
and we are heartbroken for our community.
This is terrible, this is a disaster for this
community.
But, we are pulling together; the people that
have nothing are here getting things for the
people who have nothing.”
A community hit by tragedy.
The true extent of that tragedy will only
become clear in the days ahead -- as rescuers
comb the shell of Grenfell Tower.